Emma?
You gotta
help me so that I can help you.
Dad, why do I have to talk to
you? You don't talk to me.
It is my job to help
keep you safe.
Maybe you should help yourself.
It's like she's built
this fortress around herself,
so that nothing can hurt her.
Em?
You're okay!
Hi.
Are you okay?
She's got a panic attack!
Look at me, look at me.
I know where you're at.
What did you say to her?
Oh, God.
Hi.
I wanted to say sorry
for wrecking your universe.
You coming in to check on Emma
was a very thoughtful gesture.
I did hit you both with my car.
You did.
And I am planning on suing.
I find it very easy to be in
your company. You know that?
Yeah, it's been a while for me too.
Why did you run away from me?
I'm a complicated person.
I've got baggage.
After the accident,
when I was scared,
you said that
you've been there too.
Oh, I have. A bunch of times.
- My life is a mess.
- This is good.
I've never shared this with anyone before.
I'm not perfect either.
It felt like the universe
was bringing us together.
What if this
happened for a reason?
How did your husband die?
We've all got wolves in us.
You just have to make sure
you feed the right one.
This is me.
This is who I am.